for generations Mongolian herders have
traversed this vast and pristine
countryside known as the land of the
blue sky
National Geographic emerging Explorer
Zess comic buyer grew up here
hurting yaks along the banks of the
river and normal toad king with the son
of a team they didn't tell about telling
our my lamp Mongolian say we are the
children of father sky and mother earth
party I believe this completely you know
about there is nothing more precious
but others believed Mongolia's gold
copper and coal were far more precious
than its environment mining has been a
windfall to a country long mired in
economic uncertainty but extracting and
processing gold uses up a lot of water
and creates extremely toxic waste
the aunt river used to supply water to
60,000 people and 1 million head of
livestock but a decade ago due in large
part to gold mining it ran dry tens of
thousands of people who depended on the
river were forced to move elsewhere yeah
why don't you do one being did 10 years
ago if I'm standing right here the water
level of my head monk buyers family and
neighbors dug wells to reach the water
but the groundwater was so contaminated
the dozens of local children suffered
serious liver damage my own family was
affected by the pollution we faced the
tragic loss of my mother who died
because of liver disease which he was
just given back to my son was one of the
30 or 40 children who also became ill
cancer for my channel D if I were living
in a cleaner environment monk buyer
mobilized grassroots participation among
citizens who previously felt they had no
power to shape government policy in
between similar sort of stuff but so I
saw that people started to believe that
citizens can a different
Wenlock buyer started his movement there
were 37 active mines along the Han River
in seven years he and his group have
shut down 36 mines but the government
continues to issue new permits word of
his efforts has spread around the world
a group of American Russian and
Mongolian environmentalist traverses the
countryside for a first-hand look at the
impact for the gold mining among them
National Geographic emerging Explorer
Zeb Hogan why was it important to you to
have everyone come together and see the
situation in Mongolia Mongolians say
instead of hearing something a thousand
times it's better to see it just once
Hogan studies giant freshwater fish
which are fast disappearing he's worried
that the gold mining gear is destroying
the habitat of the endangered giant
Eurasian trout known as the time in the
time n used to occur in Russia China and
Mongolia but because of activities like
class or gold mining time men have
disappeared for much of their original
range and so now the same thing that has
happened in many parts of Russia is
happening here in Mongolia gold mining
threatening the largest trout species in
the world bug buyer and others in the
movement work with herder families who
depend on the river to sustain
themselves in their livestock the group
stops to visit with sendo Chur an 82
year old nomad who's lived along the
tule River her entire life my knee has
impacted our lands a lot I can cry
seeing how my land has changed one time
I was on top of the mountain with my
grandchild and she asked me why are you
crying grandma and I said I cry Seng my
land my land is turned into other indeed
dear
passion for Lu also lives in the tule
River Valley and the shadow of russian
mining cranes because of the mining
operations the rivers dried up and we
drink the water from a puddle water
residue we don't have much pasture land
left to hurt our animals this needs to
be stopped but we don't know how so
let's get back to their cars the end but
during their ten-day trip the group also
sees positive work being done to
mitigate the damage caused by mining so
I see a total of willows over there are
those actually one mining company has
planted about a hundred thousand willow
tree saplings to help reclaim mined land
bug buyers group has also begun
restoration projects along the off river
planting bushes that could stop erosion
the bushes sweet yellow berries will
also provide income for the local
herders although more companies are
getting licenses to operate along
Mongolia's rivers mum fire is still
optimistic that with international
assistance his group and others like it
can stop destructive mining practices
the universe hasn't addressed yeah that
would be tremendous named in your
pseudonym did with ring Alstom Luke
chapter things during the last eight
years we've been trying to save our
river and our water but in the overall
picture or not succeed we can't stop all
the operations and we need to cooperate
with international organizations
fighting together we will resolve
for many Mongolians this beautiful
landscape is just as precious as gold
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium